Now when you have a decision under uncertainty and there's an opponent,
it's called game theory.
If there's no opponent, it's usually called decision under uncertainty.
There is other names.
So let's look at an example of that first before we get back to the game of pig.
Here's the decision I'm going to give you.
You're on a game show, and you won, and you get a prize of 1 million dollars or euros
or whatever currency you want to use.
Now you're given a decision.
You can keep the $1 million, or the host will flip a coin and you believe it to be a fair coin,
and if you call it correctly you get $3 million, but if you get it wrong, you get nothing.
So you analyze the outcome of this and you believe that this is a choice by the coin
that has a 50% probability of each outcome, and you want to say, what should I do?
Should I keep the million or should I go for the 3 million?
What I'm going to do is code up a model for this, and then let the decision theory decide.
First, I just define a variable million because it's hard to see the number of 0's
and count correctly.
Now traditionally, utility is used with the abbreviation U and quality with abbreviation Q.
So I'm going to define here a quality function that says, given a state and an action,
what's my--and given utility, what state is worth to me that's going to tell me
the value of that state action pair?
And the actions available to me are holding and gambling.
Let's go ahead and make that explicit.
So in any state, the actions available are holding and gambling,
where we're only going to deal with 1 state, but we make this perfectly general.
And the state that I start with is, however many dollars I have in my pocket--
could be anything.
And given that state, if I hold, my state is going to be increased by $1 million,
and then there's some utility on that--how much do I value having what I have now
plus 1 million.
And if I gamble, there's a 50% chance that I get 3 million more than I have now.
There's some utility for that.
And a 50% chance that I get nothing more than I have now, and some utility for that.
So that describes the quality of the state, but only describes it if I have a utility function.
I have to know how much do I like money?
Well, the simplest choice for utility function is the identity function.
Say the identity function just takes any input x and returns x.
It's the input itself, and so we could say, if I start with nothing,
the value of the state of having nothing is 0, and the value of the state of having
a million is a million.
Now here's--the amazing thing is, I can just write out what the optimal strategy is,
what the best action is for this state,
and what it's going to be is the maximum over all the possible actions from the state,
that was just hold and gamble,
maximized by EU, which stands for Expected Utility.
Expected meaning average.
So what's the average utility of each of the actions, and I've defined the average utility
as the quality of that state, given that state action pair under the utility function?
And that means that the Q had to deal with the averaging,
and it did that.
It said, 50% this, 50% that. That's the value of gambling.
Now this best_action function solves this particular problem.
But the amazing thing is is that we can completely generalize this,
so if we just add in parameters, now we're saying what's the best_action
in a particular state if you tell me what the available actions are,
what the quality of each state action pair is, and what the utility is over states,
then I can tell you what the best_action is.
That works for any possible domain that you can define.
It's an amazing thing that we solved all the problems at once.
Similarly to the way in search where we had 1 best_search algorithm
that could solve all of the search problems.
Now it doesn't mean that we're done, and we never have to program anything again
because programming can be difficult.
There's some problems that don't fit into this type of formulation,
and there are many, many problems which you can describe,
but which you can't solve in a feasible amount of time.
So we haven't solved everything, but it is amazing how much we can do
with just this 1 short function.
Let's go ahead and solve it.
Let's solve this problem, and let's say I start off with $100, what's my best_action?
Then when I run that, it tells me the best_action is gamble.
Now that doesn't sound quite right to me.
If you are faced with that problem, assuming you had $100 to your name.
Would you take the gamble--try to go for the 3 million,
or would you hold with 1 million?
And there's no right or wrong answer to this despite what the interface has to do.
It has to tell you one answer is right or wrong, but you can ignore that.
I just want to collect some data on how many people think that they would gamble
in that situation and how many people think they would hold.